The other type of bias that we have to
be careful about is called the, we call it the
approach bias and this bias often shows itself in the
beginning of a project or the way we approach something.
>> Yeah, we see this all the time when we've run UXD
workshops at IO, and a variety of other venues before, and almost
9 times out of 10 every developer when, when asked to build
a pizza ordering application. Thinks about
a photo realistic pizza ordering widget
that uses some really nifty graphics API said
they want to go and build right now.
>> Gosh and I was the one getting hungry.
But why do you think developers approach it this way?
>> Well, developers love to code. And when asked to design a pizza
ordering application, the first thing to think
about is what graphics API, APIs are
available on Android. And what other pinch to zoom and 3D, 4D realistic
things they can implement right now. And they want to get to it right now.
And honestly, as a developer even when I'm
designing things, in the back of my head.
>> Yep.
>> I'm always thinking, how do I build this thing? How would you approach it?
>> Well, as a designer, the way I would approach it is this. I would try to
imagine a user who's sitting there using their phone
and they're hungry for pizza. And they pull up
an application, and they want to go from being hungry
to being satisfied. And I think about, what is
the flow I could create in an application that
would let them go from being hungry to satisfied
as quickly as possible, with as little friction as possible, and
make them happy. So that's kind of the pure designer approach.
But the way that we really want to go about this
is not exactly the developer approach or the designer approach. We want
to do something that kind of meets in the middle. So,
as a development minded designer, I think what you would want to
do is design something really great, empathize with your user, but
keep constraints in mind and keep the question of whether you can
really build this in mind.
>> You know, exactly. And another thing is
you and I are very familiar with software. And
the way we think about interaction design patterns
and libraries are not the same as a user.
>> Exactly.
>> When we're building things, we have a certain bias, because
we're so familiar with these tool kits and platforms that we end
up having assumptions about how somebody will actually use a particular
widget or a control. And that's not exactly how a [INAUDIBLE] user
might do it.
>> Now that we've discussed approach bias, think about the
most recent project that you've worked on. Think about what you
did on day one or how you first approached this
project. Did any of your approaches actually bias the final product?